welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host definition
had a hell of a lot of technical issues
in the last hour or so
so unfortunately i won't be dropping a
gotham knight's reaction for a while
but you know the suicide squad trailer
well the behind the scenes look has just
dropped so we're gonna be going through
that and breaking down basically
everything that you need to know about
it
might be some spoilers here might not
don't know
continue uh you are part of the suicide
squad if you continue and kick off about
those spoilers mine i tell you that
right so let's get into the breakdown
i think it's going to surprise people
you kind of sit there and go how did
they do that
now what i really like about this is
that they're actually going to the
jungle and stuff
um one of the big runs suicide squad vs
justice league which i kind of have a
feeling that they're actually leading up
to
but they haven't really mentioned
anything yet but just the way that
things are going at dc
at the moment and with suicide squad
killer justice league being a game
i think that they're going more towards
this now this jungle setting was a big
part of that and obviously you know a
jungle setting is just a jungle setting
but it does show that the squad are
moving away from the sort of urban
environments that they were
now the new 52 run actually started off
in volume 1
in an urban setting and then it kind of
moved into more jungles because you can
do
a lot more there's animals there you
might get a cameo from someone like
cheetah who has been a part of the the
squad
a number of times and yeah it's just
nice to see them sort of
ship out to this area rather than just
being stuck in a city which we've all
seen
thousands upon thousands of times
it's going to be different from any
superhero movie ever made
and i genuinely believe that it will as
well because james gunn obviously
he got fired from disney and wasn't
allowed to do guardians of the galaxy
vol
3. and they were they were crawling back
to him after a while
but he he basically went to warner
brothers they poached him
and said look do whatever you want
here's any of the money that you want
and i think they have given him full
creative control over his
film which i definitely definitely agree
with i think warner brothers
they did kind of try and meddle a bit
too much um if you look at what happened
with justice league obviously with zack
snyder
batman v superman the ultimate cut is a
lot better than the theatrical one and
clearly there were things going on
behind the scenes
they really seem to have taken a step
back with that and things like this
are absolutely brilliant i love to see
directors getting
to actually make the movies that they
want to make because what's the point in
hiring them you know just
get get a cameraman to film whatever you
want but great
great to hear that
and we of course have polka dot man now
polkadot man is kind of a joke character
in dc um he did start off as a serious
villain all the way back in the the 60s
and 70s however since then if you read
things like the batman new 52
it's just become a bit of a joke what i
love about the lineup
is there's so many characters here and
it's a suicide squad they're just going
to be killing people off left right and
center which is what you really want to
see
the new 52 run the first five volumes
are absolutely brilliant
the last five not so much but the first
five you can tell they really had an
idea and a vision of what they wanted to
do
just bring loads of dc characters in do
whatever they wanted with them
because any of them can die it really
adds a lot of tension to it
i think it's a really really inspired
choice to do it here
and there's holly with a rocket launcher
um so it does look like this
this is going to be a big scene this
beach storming
um obviously i'm guessing there's
something at the center of the island
that they have to get a hold of
we don't know what yet there's no sign
of the joker at the moment um so that
he's going to be popping up
i kind of have a feeling that eclipso is
going to be
at the center of this now there's also
been rumors that star or the conqueror
is going to be the big bad of it this
was reported today
and starro is basically a mind control
guy so
sort of similar to what they did with
enchantress in the first film but again
when it's the suicide squad you're not
really focusing on the villains because
the squad themselves are sort of
villainous
so it makes a lot of sense and there's
little little mongol in the corner as
well
there's no one better in the world to
direct the suicide squad
i would probably agree with that i was
excited with an
opportunity to be able to do the suicide
squad in the way
it could be done from my point of view
and i think that looks
like bel reeves had a bit of a facelift
i'm trying just to skip through these
um but we did see them in a prison
obviously harley quinn's been caught
again
good doing a terrible job of finding
that scene there but we did see her kind
of walk down
some steps um at a prison so i'm
guessing that they're going back to this
location
i don't want to skip too far ahead in
case i miss anything
the character dying maybe this is a
gritty 1970s war movie
combined with brilliance of james and
shut us captain boom rang there throwing
those light
boomerangs combined with brilliance
right that's
excellent because in the first suicide
squad film i was kind of gutted that
they never
really used the boomerangs to that level
but i see them coming out dual wielding
excellent of james gunn's characters and
comedy
you need your director to set the vibe
the suicide squad
okay there was a tower there um
right okay so that looks sort of that's
in the middle of the city clearly
um where that yeah it does look like a
shot from the film i was gonna say that
just looks like a set but it's clearly
cgi
so this is clearly a shot from the film
um star of the conqueror actually does
tend to build towers when it invades and
you can also see
sort of the way that the architecture
around the tower is so
listen to how smart i sound i'm not that
intelligent at all
but you can sort of see the the prongs
coming out
and basically what it tends to do is
build a tower with uh
basically star symbols now there's a
great issue
of just jla and by grant morrison in
which star or the conqueror invades the
planet
guess who has to go in and get them
batman do you know why because
everyone else in the justice league has
superpowers except for batman
and if starro were to take over them
then they
they would basically you know the planet
would be ended but batman goes in sorted
all out
it's a really great run and i think it
does make a lot of sense
why amanda waller would choose the
suicide squad to do this job purely
because they're expendable
if they get taken over by the star that
goes on
staro's victims amanda waller can just
do the little thing in the neck that i
can't say because last time i did i got
demonetized
so it does make sense for the squad to
go in and do this mission
so they're clearly thinking of what
villains going to work in this film i
know
a couple of minutes ago i said it
doesn't matter what villain it is
clearly they've thought this out it's
great and obviously if
starro took over then the justice league
would be called him so
yeah sending in the the front line here
the suicide squad is just a twisted
fantasy
of characters within each of their
characters there's a certain beauty
with them as we saw some of them are
just pretty certain
so that is played by sean gunn i kind of
think that sean gunn gets a bit of a
bad rap on these movies because he he
also did the the green screen for rocket
raccoon
in avengers end game and guardians of
the galaxy bradley cooper provided the
voice over but
sean gunn was the one doing all the work
and
it gets to be in films and stuff but
yeah a little rap but obviously this is
the prison as well than most of them
some of them are just pretty crappy
through and through be like a
douchey captain america the guy who
believes in
peace at any cost no matter how many
people he needs to
kill along the way absolutely love that
that is the perfect way to do
peacemaker i can't it just looks like
there's a mask floating there
you can't really see anything it's
strange that they've kind of filmed this
just a picture of a blurry jeep here
um but that's quite quite weird but
peacemaker obviously
um he's insane and he basically went
over the top
trying to be a vigilante and just killed
loads of people as they mentioned
and he is he is pretty much captain
america if he if he was killing everyone
which
captain america does kill a lot of
people okay i got it
don't ever settle back like you think
you know where this is going because
you don't as soon as you have some sense
about what's about to happen next
james comes in and i'm so
happy hearing that because that is
something in the new 52 run that i
absolutely loved whenever things settled
down whenever
you thought it was easy some a character
would either die or something big would
happen someone would betray the other
characters and try and escape
and it does sound like they've really
captured the dynamism here which i'm
very very excited for
everyone is exploding genitals heads
arms legs
it's like a big that's getting
demonetized graphic novel
brought to life this is by far the
biggest movie i've ever made
he's throwing polka dots by the looks of
it and there's king shark
um also getting a big bite on a
character so king shock is basically a
whole character
very small brain though so uh not
intelligent but
excellent i don't think that you know
what to expect
i don't don't get too attached no hype
that's good
truly the greatest
most exciting journey of my life making
this film
amazing it was great
so yeah that's the trailer um prediction
captain boomerang's gonna die
that's just my thoughts obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on it
so comment below let me know you know
how it goes
when we do the heavy spoiler show if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our trailer breakdown of wonder woman
1984 which is going to be linked at the
end
hopefully see you next time take care
much love
you